hello
we are live
let's uh do this
sweet
these nuts what's up
uh casey sportstern mr gaming brent
lord how am i too fast right now
what is up everybody hello good morning
good afternoon good night
uh wherever you are right now good
that good time of day to you hello how
is it going
love to everybody that is in india
australia
the world uk america asia
all the places how's everybody doing are
we ready to figure out
what lady loki's plan is and i do think
she is lady loki i uh i don't think
she's enchantress
but we shall see won't we
let's pull up disney plus and let's also
pull up hey that's me that's a watch
party
uh can the question is are my uh is my
audio
okay let's check this out
looks like everything's all right sounds
like everything's all right
cool everything sounds good
sakin the gum what you what you think in
episode three um
i'm ready to find out excuse me i'm
ready to find out lady loki's plan this
really
is what i is what i really want um
i i'm sorry let me turn this on i'm i'm
hoping that's what i'm hoping that's
what we find out i'm hoping we find out
lady lucky's plan and i hope it's a good
one
and i kind of hope she's actually good
like you know there there's a there's
something
she's trying to take down that's bad
right like she like maybe it's kang and
she knows it's kang and she's like i
gotta take him down because
you know they don't even know they don't
even know it's king themselves and etc
etc oh jake hedge what's up man
thank you so much always supporting
always supporting chris is about to get
on i believe
i think i just heard him walk down the
hallway walk up the stairs and walk down
the hallway
i'm just gonna pull up uh loki here and
make sure that episode three is not out
yet okay so i bet those
episode three is not out yet but what
are uh
what are everybody's thoughts uh huh
what everybody's
it's gonna block my face there we go
what are everybody's thoughts
on on loki um on episode three what do
we think it's gonna happen
todd andrew do i trust the tva or do
they have a hidden agenda um
i feel like this question has uh
i feel like i answer this question in
two different ways
do do i do i trust like owen wilson's
character mobius do i trust
um do i trust that the members
of the tva think they're doing what's
right
yeah i i believe that they believe
what they're doing is right however the
timekeepers not so much
um i'm sticking with my my
theory that kang is the uh
is one of the timekeepers or kang might
just be like the only only person in
charge but he's like
made up these time keepers you know just
to like
kind of use them for whatever reason he
wants i saw a theory
saying the tv is in the quantum realm
thoughts i did a whole video
on that today um the mock thanks for
that super chat uh if you want you can
watch that we probably have enough time
but uh
yeah i uh i think there's a lot of proof
for it i think there's a lot of evidence
for it i just realized we're watching
myself here
um
yeah yeah it's like so chin i think i'm
saying that right i'm so sorry if i'm
not um
i think uh i think they believe they're
doing the right thing
i don't think i think this is crooked is
what i think
uh i don't think um i don't think people
like
owen wilson know i i don't think they
know that um
that the tva probably has a different
agenda you know
let's see something john haynes what is
up thank you for that super chat it may
just be me
but this minute seems super sad like i
seriously think she knows when more than
she's letting on
like what even is she yeah so actually i
just read an article today
uh by the voice actress um man i can't
remember her name that's my fault
um i know it too i've said it many times
but she said we definitely
uh haven't seen
the last of her um and basically that
there
there's basically there's more coming
um so i'm i'm betting
she's either in charge right like it's
it's the person in charge and that's
like
an ai that he uses to kind of watch over
everything and stuff like that
um there's more to her yes
uh ishmael montoya is mobius they look a
variant i don't believe so i i don't
think so i
i think he was indeed created by the tva
uh
i don't i don't know if the tv are gods
or um
or if it's kang and he's just figured
stuff out you know
um but i do believe that the tva was
created by
by something by higher power uh
no worries dude i i know uh
i i know a lot of uh i know it's like
you know
hard to catch every video no worries no
worries no worries uh but yeah go ahead
and go ahead and check that out if you
want i think we have you know we have
like
i would say 25 minutes until we begin
because uh disney seems to be releasing
the episodes pretty early i
just want to make sure i'm not missing
any super chats i appreciate everybody
in the chat
as always of course i appreciate the
super chats and i appreciate
my moderator mr anderson who always does
an amazing job
welcome welcome welcome uh
sarath biswas do i think we'll see all
the places
whose names are on the rinse layer thing
i hope so i hope they're gonna send
different people to different times
those were very specific time
or places and times of course uh that we
saw
you know ego was one of them titan was
one of them
i'm hoping they they at least put some
tva agents out there
and show us what the heck is going on uh
hello philippines
hello people from the philippines hello
people from all over the world i saw
australia saw whales philippines
everybody
who it's super late for in the us right
now
t aurora loki day let's go um
hello to the world hello to the world
uh hello aegon jack
srirena hello bob evans
lady loki is the same in game load
keeper from the future um so in the
comics
uh lady loki is a reincarnated version
of loki so there's
there's nothing that really says that um
that that can't happen and hasn't
happened in the future you know
um we have to keep that in mind um
we have to keep that in mind that it's
it's it's
i follow fine and i i know a lot of
people do follow fine but when you have
a show that's like time travel and
everything like that
um you know it gets a little um
complicated and convoluted sometimes but
keep in mind tva exists outside
of time excuse me and
also keep in mind that
future events have already happened
and we could see anything from the
future events which is kind of trippy
when you think about it
like when you think about it whatever's
gonna happen
with lady loki could have already
happened now obviously the new events
aren't gonna
haven't already happened because she's
kind of creating you know all these new
different timelines and stuff like that
um tva is in the quantum realm
controlled by kane what do you think uh
that's the actual title
of my video that i did today so i i
think yes i think yes uh do i have a
girlfriend yes
um yeah yes
is that a lot of people asking no just
one person yes i do is lady lucky
no i don't think lady lucky is the same
loki from endgame from the future no
uh in studios you know i've seen a lot
of things about enchantress
and i don't think it's her i think um
i think marvel did their hella slash um
oh i need to fix something real quick uh
marvel did their hella slash enchantress
for ragnarok right they already admitted
that
right they already excuse me oops sorry
they already admitted that they kind of
fused two characters in the one now
could they fuse entrance enchantress
with lady loki
yeah and they probably did do a little
bit of that you know so
[Music]
who's to say it's not both i and i
personally think it is a little bit of
both
one thing that is for sure is
our r
r loki it's kind of weird saying are
loki because it's not the same one
that died in in-game which i consider
are loki but i'm going to say for like
our argument say are looking the main
loki of this show
um
is um i totally lost
my train of thought because
level back to india yeah you tell them
mr anderson
um i have no idea what i'm saying guys
i'm sorry i think i like read a comment
and then like i
completely lost my mind there um
oh i remember our loki is inferior
to lady loki i do think lady loki is
like
light years beyond what our loki is
excuse me i need to
take some drink out of my tv cup
i think ismail montoya thank you for
that super chat i think o slash u means
over under
25 percent that variant lines will cross
red line i
and and if it is over under i'm gonna
have to say over um
i think i think for sure this
is i think for sure this is um
the start of the multiverse i just saw
somebody
uh junkie remix is miss minutes the same
thing as jarvis no i think she's an
actual
i think there's something more to her
than than we look
uh arcade ape hey warren is loki
happened before one division so here's
the funny thing about that i wanted to
address that
question because it's actually kind of
funny
it takes place outside of time
right so no
it takes place before it takes place
after it's not really at a point in time
which is the really weird part you know
um it's it's weird
because they exist outside of time so
now if you want to put things into
perspective our loki was taken from 2012
and then kidnapped so that would be
before
so when he was taken that happened
before but the tva exists
outside of time so it's it's really it's
really nothing
king j thanks for that super chat since
stanley passed away and he won't be in
any
new marvel movie what if they do old man
kappa's new stan lee who
cameo in every marvel movie yeah i think
that would be funny
i think that would be funny but i i
definitely think that marvel is going to
stick to
stan lee uh remember what we saw in the
the venom trailer
uh he was a like on the front cover
newspaper
and what was the it was it was low-key i
think the first episode there it looked
like there was cameo of him on the wall
there was like a mural in the courtroom
and that looked like him uh and i think
they'll continue to do that i'm all for
the idea
that i don't know who put this idea out
there read it somewhere and a lot of
people are talking about it now
i'm off for the idea of uh
of deadpool doing like cameos because i
think that would be hilarious some
there was i can't remember who
who uh i can't remember who talked about
that but
uh i i'm all for that idea
um it's not out yet guys i just checked
i'll check again
nope only episode one and two as soon as
it gets going
we shall watch um i should test my sound
though let's try this
question is can y'all hear that because
i can't have y'all hearing that
because if y'all hear that i'm getting
copyrighted
and that's not that's not good for me
i like to be able to do these things i
like to be able to show you guys just a
little bit because i know some people
don't
don't have disney plus i wish i could
show you the whole thing i should play
audio the whole entire time
oh i really wish so but that would uh
that would be a
bad thing for me and disney so yeah uh
let's
kratos yeah her name is sylvie luffy
daughter which
uh is means daughter of lafayette uh
who was the frost giant so yeah like
that's a great point that you brought up
because i've been talking about
questions
uh about enchantress or not no i i think
she's loki i i think she is a variant
of loki i i don't think she's
enchantress even though her name is
sylvie i know enchantress's name is
sylvie
uh but even though her name is sylvia i
i don't think
i don't think that white isn't coming to
india yet
wish i had the power to tell you my
friend uh
man i don't i don't know i don't know
also i have not seen episode three i've
only i
only got to screen the first uh two
episodes
i did see black widow though and i
enjoyed that
i'll give it like uh i think i give it a
7.5 out of 10.
i just i it's i liked it
i mean i really liked it um
i like go back and forth on whether or
not i believe that she should have got
more time
or or if like
they did what they did and it was like a
really good thing and they did they did
what they did and it is a really good
thing
and i i like the movie i think it was
really really good really really really
really really good
all right
i'm checking right now to see if uh
to see if more nope not yet
um i would say probably in about i would
say nine minutes marvel
or disney is going to release it because
they always um they always tend to
release it a little bit early
which bless their hearts it's already
super late or earlier in the middle of
afternoon for all of us
it's uh it's super late for me um and i
get really tired really tired
um yeah um i see a few
people talking about richard
grant and um manav patel
yeah um we haven't seen his character
yet i think he might be a time keeper
um
but i mean really he he could be
he could be anyone because they can go
to any different point in time
right he he could be a future
somebody right hawkeye or something
right i mean yeah
it's out in india out in india out in
india
well is it out in the u.s
not out in the us so good for you india
you think this episode sat vik mishra i
think in this episode
multiverse will not go into madness the
garlic it will start the multiverse at
the end yeah i i'm thinking that as well
i think they're gonna like
i think they're gonna kind of um set
things straight
eventually i think they're gonna cancel
out those uh branches that were created
i do believe they're going to cancel
those branches and then i think uh
i think at the end like you said i think
at the end that's when it's all gonna
that's when it's all gonna be just going
down
i think because you know climactically
there has to be a climax
um so yeah mitchell zlaggy thank you so
much for that super chat
really appreciate it uh
looks like it's it's out for you and
you're in minnesota
in turmoil resting
i don't have it yet you know what's
uh you know what's funny is this has not
crashed yet
you know uh for one division and for the
falcon of the winter soldier we had uh
disney plus crashing on us a little bit
now they fixed it in like a few minutes
but
we haven't had a crash yet
so oh i turned the ac down super cold
so i could wear a jacket in here even
though my pcs are running and
and uh and yeah oh that's a good
axe shot do you think the time keepers
are king movies and loki
not gonna lie that'd be pretty fire
that'd be uh that'd be pretty that'd be
pretty insane
right if we get to the end and it's like
loki is actually that would be
i would like that loki's one of the time
keepers at the end that would uh
that would be pretty sick actually i i'd
be all for that
dang out in india on netflix okay now i
know
people are joking netflix that's funny
so i i know yeah hey jf what's up man
good to see you yeah i um
they probably did upgrade their servers
totally i mean they would have had you
right because right now they got the bad
batch
rolling out too right definitely uh iron
man 4
new i uh i do not know
i do not know anything about iron man 4.
uh haven't heard anything the latest
we've heard is captain america for
which you know i'm up for that
i almost spit out my drink because i
just read fay as hussein what if kang is
mephisto
wouldn't it be great if just at like one
point
mephisto came and he was somebody that
we like completely unexpected
like
i see a few people asking about um
uh spider-man no way home uh i haven't
heard anything that's why i haven't done
a video about it um
i wish i could tell you guys some good
news uh i really do i wish i could tell
you guys some good news
um unfortunately i haven't heard
anything
kind of heard something about uh from
daniel rpk
stating that um
it might be like later half of july
which
which would suck um
maybe maybe it comes with black widow
i'm just thinking
uh do i have a patreon no but i am
starting memberships very soon i uh i've
been i've been thinking
i've been working on that lately um
starting membership so
i'm gonna be doing uh member only live
streams
uh gonna do do member only like uh watch
parties because on discord
we can uh you know show the movie and
watch it and it can't be copyrighted
that way or at least i don't think it
could maybe it could
but uh we're gonna try it right um we're
gonna have emojis all that stuff member
badges
i'm gonna do some videos that are gonna
be for members only
um and i think
i think there's gonna be some cool stuff
in there because you know a lot of the
times when i you know do my videos
you know each day i um i don't
i don't talk about the little news
that kind of goes by each day and
sometimes there's a few you know good
pieces of news that comes out
and uh you know i only talk about like
one thing unless it's one of those
videos where
i like put a lot of different uh
subjects into one video which sometimes
i do um
but i think there's a lot of videos that
i'm gonna do where it's just me on
camera talking
uh and there's gonna be members only
videos so
what headset do i have this is a razer
um
i don't know what racer it is uh
because i actually got it from chris for
christmas or my birthday or something i
don't know
uh not out yet guys i see some people
asking me to check no not yet maybe in a
few minutes
uh did i watch the icarly reboot no i
haven't because i actually
i don't know what i thought it was um
i thought it was like a one-time thing i
thought it was just like one episode
and it's it's it's not it's a whole new
series which like i didn't even know
so of course like i want to watch it um
but i haven't started it yet so i i will
i will for sure because that's like my
child
uh how many languages do i speak basmala
rabbah let's see um english
dutch korean
i'm not gonna count french
because one i haven't spoken in a really
long time
and two i probably couldn't have an
actual conversation with somebody
past hi how are you yes i'm good where
is you know
the louvre and stuff like that so i'll
come that and then spanish so
four uh english korean
dutch spanish four
scottish mephisto how funny would that
be black widow spoilers i can't
post any of black widow spoilers guys i
won't get any screenings if i do
is live it was live is loki alive or
dead
and the present capped in the present
captain america we're just holding
timeline oh he's dead
uh well the loki
that we've been following in the mcu's
dead right there as
as we've learned there are a lot
of different versions of loki so there
are definitely some loki
how how can i speak dutch it's break on
patreon netherlands and
nitsa hoot um
and i'd have to tell the story in
english because um
hold on i saw a cool question mary kill
mary kiss one division [ __ ] winner
soldier loki
uh i'm gonna marry loki ah
no no no no i'm gonna i'm gonna marry
loki kiss one division i i'd probably
kill the [ __ ]
but i love them all both and one
division i probably actually i actually
probably liked uh falcon or soldier a
little bit more
than uh than one division but both were
great um how many press credit scenes
are there um in blackwood i just saw one
and i you know i checked a few times um
and i learned dutch because i have a lot
of friends
actually live in netherlands and i've uh
i've been there a few times myself
and that's why i learned it all right
lamentus
oh look at that thumbnail all right guys
here it comes we're about to start
is everybody ready because we're
starting
right now all right
and then so starting right here it's
obviously the recap right so
is a recap right now we're started
all right all right
what we got what we got
i'm not interested in ruling the time
variance authority
interesting
recap right now yeah
hara street car some people some person
was asking me about like
a recent black widow leak and i was like
i can't say anything because i already
know now
like i can't say anything now
oh i like this music
let me make sure though
all right here we go
interesting choice of music where are we
at where are we at where we at
oh look it's her
oh look
it's her
this is weird
interesting
it's not the judge it's a b-20
the one who was who she took hostage
last time
how many people are guarding the
timekeepers
oh it's like an illusion
yeah it's an illusion
she's tricking her she's
how many people are guarding the
timekeepers
i know this place i remember it
took now oh
oh so this is her
this is how she
this is how she's finding the time
keepers
yup wow wow
well and she sees them coming oh
then we have the loki mart dang son
all right oh look who's in
[Music]
she's in
[Music]
oh she's just taking everybody out
oh her powers didn't work on this guy oh
no
dang she's kicking all their butts
dude that's epic
i love her and there's loki
dude she's like awesome
like crazy awesome
lucky she's oh look he got his knives
what up
and here she comes
and she's just kicking everybody's butts
dang
oh that was cool you're in my way you
are my way
wants to work together she does not or i
should say look he does not
you like vision
oh look he's
uh oh judge rinslayer found them
oh he activated a portal to where
and they're there together
oh
oh
oh the battery's low they can't move
oh no
oh dude did he just teleport
can loki teleport
don't ever call me loki
she said don't ever call me a loki
oh someone just
oh all right here's that scene from the
trailer
they are at lamentus one which i have no
idea what that means does anybody in the
chat know what that means
it's got to be in the future i guess
2077.
there's stuff on from the slot sky
and uh wow this is awesome
oh this is the worst apocalypse no one
makes it off here
wow
dang we're a team now
oh there comes a big fireball
looking cold or weird you're so weird
wow that's funny dang
that's funny
dang alright so they have to work
together now or they're both gonna die
bet you he's an illusion
oh what you about to do she's gonna kiss
him
they're trying to jot me it won't work
because my mind is too strong
[Laughter]
i love this
huh loki proposes a truce
i love loki oh i love her too
she's awesome i think i'm in love with
both loki's
her plan was years in the making years
tell us your plan
tell us your plan
we just need enough power to travel
through intimate interdimensional time
and space
okay all right
the title is lamentis one which is the
planet they're on right now which a moon
is about to crash into
or they're on a moon that's about to
crash to a planet
what's the plan
can you shut up i love her
oh she just he just called her a variant
don't call me variant he's the one with
a
jacket on
oh oh she said it she's so big she's not
loki anymore
she's silly
independence authority style that's what
makes a loki
tell us plan
uh the episode's only 42 minutes long
so they're on a very star wars like
planet and city of course it is the
future it's 2077.
hmm
12 hours or so until the planet blows up
collapse of society that's always a bad
thing
thanks isaiah richardson i don't think
she's enchantress i think they're just
kind of fusing the two characters
but yeah sylvia is enchantress but she
did say she used to be loki
she just changed her name has an alias
now and her
alias is sylvie and i'm definitely in
love with sylvie
slash loki and this is a really cool
episode so far i really like it
this just feels very star wars to me and
i really like it i'm like really digging
the star wars webs
diplomacy and guile you tell them loki
oh soon as she opened the door she got
hit
oh who's this
i enjoyed it she said
oh he's gonna oh he just transformed it
to her husband
look
interesting that's rude
oh come on loki
she's gonna shoot him yep dang
that's funny
he never she just said there's been many
you're not travelers you're devils
the fish don't confirm let's not start
all right lady who are you what do you
devils want with me
her eyes were glowing green
ark the evacuation vessel
how do we get to the ark train station
but you'll never get a ticket
interesting
uh timestamp sorry guys let me get that
with you right now
uh 15.45
this episode seems to be about 41
minutes long
interesting so everyone's evacuating to
the ark
so what's their plan
look you turned into the guard
follow my lead
interesting i got on they're only giving
tickets to the wealthy
interesting yeah everybody else does
look kind of wealthy
are they going to stop him
she enchanted him because
oh they're on they're on they're on
all right so they're on a ship now and
like all the wealthy people are on the
ship
and
loki's kill
look he said i can't go backwards on a
train
i can't sleep around untrustworthy
people
he just said his mother taught him magic
and struck a chord with her
what was she like
the queen of asgard
she was good
she said she knew she was adopted she
said yeah they told me did i tell you
she barely remembers her mother
they're talking about their mother
mothers
you want to see oh look he's doing
fireworks
they're bonding not bad
she did oh he has a hard time with his
mother anyone would
you taught yourself that magic
it'd be easier if i just enchanted you
look he took her champagne because she
didn't want any
maybe love is hate
love is hate
she said piss off which means she's
oh
oh
a bit of both
he had princes and princesses waiting
for him
but nothing ever real just like her
love his mischief that's pretty good
he says no
love is white loki
something i'll have to have another
drink to talk about
what is about to happen
well there's the ark i'm assuming oh no
that's a that's a freaking
part of the moon crashing into the
planet
i'm getting real star wars vibes from
from this
interesting
people
well he's singing some asgardian song
he's singing an asgardian song
hey lucky we have the same jacket buddy
[Laughter]
he's so dang charming
ah he said to sylvie everybody
he said another then he threw it on the
ground like thor did i love it
hahaha
he's drunk it's hilarious
love is a dagger
it's a weapon to be wilted
far away or up close
it's beautiful until it makes you bleed
but when you reach for it that isn't
real interesting
terrible metaphor dang i thought i had
something there
cut
oh there we go and there we go oh
silvia's going at it
oh took off the crown
the horns
oh he just used magic to like actually
shoot like a blast of magic
boom getting stuff done
oh wow interesting dude
okay oh oh oh oh
awful throw
and there he is he kicked that person
out of the window
oh they're gonna throw him oh they threw
him out the window
and then she jumps out the window okay
well he has the thing so he had she had
to jump out of the window
okay what you gonna do now
oh he broke it
oh it's like super broken
whoa oh hell yeah
he said you can't beat them and she got
pissed
dang
all right come on tell us the story tell
us the story come on
what's what's going on
she's super cute
i know the two of them are the same
person but they'd make an awesome couple
did you scream make you feel better
yes
yep
what about the ark
huh interesting
hijack the ark make sure it gets off the
planet
yep
she said okay i'm liking these two man
i really am
i've never walked as much in my life
the location is lamentis one it's a
future
it's a planet that we don't know it's in
the future 2077.
how does enchantment work
did i drink any 90s stuff now that is
banned i don't know what mmm
is i don't drink alcohol so if it's like
a drink drink no i haven't
but if it's like surge i've drank surge
before
interesting
hundreds of years prior before she
fought for them oh
before she joined she wasn't created
she's a regular person
all the time so they're all just
variants oh so the freaking tva
is okay okay so we learned a lot of new
info there that's awesome
she just said do we trust each other and
he said we do and we can
she said good because this is gonna suck
oh it's like an
actual like rocket ship
granted a huge rocket ship
this kind of reminds me this kind of
reminds me of
zelda majora's mask how like the moon's
about to crash into the world
oh getting intense
i'm just like in the middle of it all
trying to get on this thing
oh and there's
oh it's freaking cracking and oh that
ain't good
oh that ain't good make your move loki's
oh they got hit
they're up they're up
why are they oh he just used some
freaking cool magic
why are they trying to fight him the
world's ending holy crap
give it a rest people
well they're having a hard time there
hey francine thanks so much
yeah i don't even know what like that's
like a future language so
the planet that they're on who knows
oof big uh big big scenes here
oh that guy just got smushed hardcore
what
the hell did he just do
dude holy crap these stupid guards it's
the end of the world
why are they fighting people holy crap
and they missed it
oh thanks black bear the iron man chair
alright so that took off so they're not
on it so they're gonna die
yep
dude loki has some powers that we never
knew he had
telekinesis that seemed to be what it
was right it almost looked like
he reversed it is that the end of the
episode
oh that's the episode
whoa 36 minutes that's that's a quick
episode is there a post credit scene
well that is the end
or is that a post credit no that's not
post credit
whoa
well
interesting i was not expecting the
episode to end like that
whoa that was a lot shorter and it
wasn't an abrupt
ending j yeah this was uh there was
important parts of this episode but this
was kind of a filler episode huh
and there's only six episodes
interesting
[Music]
dang it
i'm looking i'm trying to like here i'll
just pull this up on the screen now
i'm trying to pull up like you know
easter eggs and stuff here
or easter eggs anything i could find
i'll move this here
let's see if we can find anything and in
the post credit scene here
no what oh that's just the thing from
before please sign here the kitty cat
uh no that's the same thing that's
before
uh no it wasn't earth it was lamentous
one dude that's so this right here i'm
sorry i think that's jonathan majors
that's i'm not sorry i've been saying
that for a while i think that's jonathan
majors wow this was uh
a big cliffhanger episode it almost felt
like a filler episode
you know like it it had so much
in it it really did and you know what
they established was uh
what they established was make sure
there's no post credit scene
nope no post credit scene all right what
they established was
um was the fact that
the tva
all the people weren't created by the
time keepers they are variants of other
people
which means morbius is going to write a
freaking jet ski and that's all i care
about right now
uh so basically
you know so it's like i said before the
chat
i i think that somebody asked me if i
think
that the tvs is good or secretly bad
and i think that the people who work for
the tva are good
but i think they're being tricked by the
tva which we just found out they are
which is which is definitely pushing me
more towards
kang is behind everything like
100 percent let's get chris up and here
and then i gotta move this way
this way
yeah loki has so much more magical
powers
uh than before
i was calling you
can you talk i don't think i can hear
you
shake your head yes if you can hear me
i can't hear him all right hold on voice
and video
microphone chris are you there
crash chris can't hear me
yes mobius is a variant for those asking
hello i don't hear chris
now i hear christopher
in the not on position
how do i hold on
i'm gonna put you here and i'm gonna
move back over here
we're gonna move this a little bit like
this
i think i think uh josiah yeah loki is
bi they definitely established
they definitely established that in this
how do i fool
yeah they called him gender fluid is
what they
yeah that's me
i'm warren this is this is christopher
nice
members are coming for my channel too
here's chris so
kind of a big cliffhanger that i'm not
excited about
wow there was a lot that happened in the
series in this episode
a lot and i mean the biggest part
obviously was
the tva members weren't created but they
are actually variants who were kind of
stolen and then had their brain wash
so
[Music]
dude i'm dude i'm telling you i called
it i'm calling it like
kang is in charge the timekeepers aren't
real
yeah the timekeepers aren't real kang is
the master of
uh we can't hear chris chris keep
talking
but um definitely trying to can we
figure it out
can you hear chris can i hear chris now
can you hear chris now
the suspense is killing me can i switch
our blocks you can manipulate them
however you want you can make me full
screen that's what i do to you how do i
do that hey
i did no that's me how do i make there
we go click click me
how do i how do i no hold on i want you
on the other side
is that what this means oh do you think
that mobius will realize he
is just a tool for the timekeepers and
have the other variants for both against
the tva
a superchat from jake hedge thank you
very much um i think that's probably the
direction we're heading i don't think
you get owen wilson
just to play a sidekick role do you
right he's gonna be
some kind of super dude and he's gonna
make a big difference at the end there
it's uh it didn't make sense to me so
here's one thing that i always thought
like
you're the tva right okay you're the
time keepers right
and you create a bunch of people in
civilization right
right why don't they all look the same
right why did you make people
personally different and have
personalities why aren't they just
people designed to
do your will so here's a good good
thought then and right off of what
you're saying and actually off of what
you were talking about last week with
the jet skis
oh and wilson you're going to get your
own wilson jet ski that's what i said
when the episode ended i was like i'm
totally like j owen wilson is totally
going to end the series
writing a jet going back and i love it
to his normal life
so they're all variants right and
they're going to get to get their own
time branch
they're going to get their own time
branch the tva has to end dismantled
right yeah yeah yeah for sure based off
of just the logic of my
hey that's my company
your company is fake but think about how
big
think about the city you know
how big that city is how many people are
there
yeah that is a lot of variance that is a
lot of time branches i mean
i don't see how loki ends that we don't
have a multiverse of madness
yeah and it sounds like
it was 2077 the furthest we've been
or was the episode two where was rox
cart
what year was that does anybody in the
chat remember that 20 20 50 right yeah
so 2017
so time still exists sylvie who is like
i know her name is sylvie
she's not enchantress guys i yeah yeah
just i told everybody the same thing
she's not it's
not levi thank you for joining us yes i
understand that enchantress's name
is sylvie but she did say she was loki
she just has an alias now so she
confirmed
she's a variant of loki um she was told
that she's adopted
uh they're they're they're so they
yeah i was disappointed with the episode
it was i was there were really good
parts that i really enjoyed and
in the beginning i was like dang i love
this episode like i love how it started
i love the dynamic between the two of
them and i don't know how weird this is
but if they get
together i'm not mad about it i know
this is
the same thing i was literally saying
like is it okay
with yourself it's not a sister not a
sister it's technically yourself
and it brings you back to the game of
thrones conundrum you watch like the
first few episodes and you're like oh my
gosh they're all making out with their
siblings but then by the end you're kind
of rooting for it
you get all turned around never watch
game of thrones i can't say that
anybody who has knows what i'm talking
about you're kind of rooting for the
incest but this isn't even incest this
is just two separate beings who are very
similar
cool i i i i want them to give
loki went so deep into i guess we don't
have to say anymore because we have a
name for her
and sylvia sylvie is yeah loki that's
that's the story
from here so loki went so deep and in
depth with her he opened up in a way
we've never seen him even at his most
vulnerable with mobius because she
he didn't open up like that he said the
magic
she said the magic words right and
which gets it and i gotta get this
episode every time and i understand that
because i love my mother
yeah but it is um
love yourself um love yourself that's
the
that's the point of loki that's the main
message that they're trying to get out
is love yourself but um
so i think it's super cool to see the
episode definitely
covered a lot of plot points from the
first two episodes didn't really
give us a whole lot but i think it was
tom hiddleston today
who i read the quote was after the
fourth episode things get
crazy so we're headed in that direction
so five and six
five and six are gonna blow our mind so
here here's the deal
um today was the third
super overwhelming um yeah yeah i mean
we got some pretty crazy
we got a lot out of it and i personally
just died
it did i'll be back in 30 seconds keep
going i can hear you yeah
i um i enjoyed a lot about the episode
it was definitely
the lesser of the three so far um i'm
gonna say
i'm gonna say they've declined
in order so one was the best two was
second best three was
oh you think number one was the best now
yeah uh
because you were kind of flip-flopping
there i still am flip flop yeah because
i just love the ending of episode two so
much but that's not what we're talking
about right now
uh right right right
yeah i mean we learned a lot we learned
a lot the biggest reveal was about the
tva
and i think i think we just okay here's
what we just found out
there is a villain that is not
right there is something going on
there's a villain and it's not
sylvie right sylvie is good
but from our perspective from loki
working for the tva and all that stuff
she was bad right
because she's trying to take down the
tva which we just learned is bad so if
you're trying to take down something
that's bad you're good
right math or science it all comes back
to that same free will you know
the the freedom of
choice and agency and everything that
loki said in the first episode is what
she's
after i'm sure she has a something
happened moment that we haven't gotten
to yet well
she said she's been running her whole
life from the tva did you catch that
yeah she said her whole life she's been
running from the tva
which is which is weird because like oh
okay okay okay okay so the tva has
clearly taken
people like variants and stuff did they
try to take her
maybe they tried to take her as like a
variant maybe they deemed her the best
of the best out of all the variants
so they weren't supposed to be mobius
but she was too good
and uh yeah
have a good night darvax thank you for
joining so is
um renslayer in on it
yeah i think she's kang's i think she
has to be i think she's king's lover
i think because i don't think the
timekeepers are real
i mean i don't think you don't think
that timekeepers exist no you think it's
just kang i think it's
[Music]
whether it's an illusion or he's all
three of them and they're different
variants of him
yeah i i i don't believe they exist
i and if they do their product of king
or our kang
i don't think they're they're themselves
i don't think there are these beans
that are time keepers um right i don't i
don't buy that
and since rent slayer in the comics is
the love of kang right it's just too
tantalizing
and she talks to the timekeepers
apparently she's the only one who talks
to the timekeepers
yeah i'm gonna say she's in on it mm-hmm
um go ahead
no i just that's where i'm at right now
i think
and for those of you who saw warren's
video today good job i hope you liked it
for those of you who didn't there's a
theory going around right now
that the tva are the quantum city that
we saw
in ant-man i'm i
and i think i i believe it's more
sensitive i think it makes even more
sense now
and that's what i was about
king's home city he's creating his own
and he's created it
and he's created his own world and his
little minions an illusion yeah i
i i i think this is what's happening i
think kang
is behind all of this i think they're in
chronopolis inside of the quantum realm
i think he
has tricked all these people
because who kang is the master of time
travel
he's the one grabbing all the variants
and then he created his own plan
all the stuff playing everything he
that's got to be what it is
right so that's my point if what we're
saying right now about the variance and
how the tva is just going to crumble
because it's all going to fall apart is
true
this has to connect to the movie that is
literally called quantum mania
right right exactly and what's the
connecting point here
does ant-man discover
these discover kang and this is the big
connection there and we're only going to
get a hint of kang here
what's the story about that yeah so what
if
what if like they all just eventually
like what if they all
what if the city explodes
and everybody dies what chris what what
if every single person
that makes it out of the tva alive
become mutants oh that would be really
cool
[Laughter]
well if you're
applying janet van dyne rules of study
inside of the quantum realm for so long
right she developed powers that's where
the fantastic four could come from which
is maybe even more likely like there's
so many directions that can happen with
this
if the tva members even if a handful of
them escape not all of them because
there's probably millions of them in
there the city's huge
oh for sure uh they don't all make it
out no daniel diaz thanks for super chat
do i think the tva will appear in
ant-man no i actually think tva is gonna
be completely blown up after after this
i think so
loki so
[Music]
i just thought of something else
the tesseract doesn't work because it
travels through space
the quantum realm exists outside of
space exactly
and it also exists outside of time which
is why things like the time stone and
all the other stuff doesn't work
because in in game they said
that they create the reality of whatever
universe they're in or timeline that
they're in well if they're outside of
all that
they're useless
they gotta be in the quantum realm i
mean it's gotta it's gotta be
that city had to be shown for a reason
so like regardless of whatever it is
that city is where kang is
because kangaskhan events
that city inside of the quantum realm is
100 chronopolis
is that where the tva is i think so it's
not confirmed obviously
but yeah well where else is outside
of space and time you know think take
all your your huge knowledge of the
comics and
other mentions from the mcu i can't
recall anything ever
outside of space and time other than the
quantum realm or what do they call it in
the comics it's not called the quantum
realm it's called the
oh what's it called i can't think of the
title right now what's wrong i can't do
there
the miniverse chronosphere or something
no just the
what the quantum realm is called sphere
i think it's called
something something it's the same thing
there isn't
somewhere else that's outside next to
time in between parallel universes
so where else could the tva be ladies
and gentlemen my wife
she's gone um you're coming here too
go say hi you can say hi to everybody
what you're not on screen it looks like
trash that's what everybody hears you
you could come say hi
no one can see my camera is literally
pointing this way
that's my why you see this screen right
here that's what you have to pop into
hi there pop your little pop your little
head in oh wow we got a hand everybody
that's everybody cat the famous
everybody give a big round of applause
to ali for the
famous tick-tocker the famous micro
reverse that's what it is thank you
mike reverse thank you thank you thank
you the microverse which i think they
don't have the right to use
that title no they don't microsphere
thank you jake you're correct
microverse so yeah i mean there's really
nowhere else the tva could be even if
it's not that city maybe that's a
separate city that kang has but
it's definitely in the quantum realm
that's the point yeah yeah hold on i got
super chat daniel thank you so much uh
there was unused footage in a homecoming
trailer
where the vulture flies through the
marquee building
and it was also shown in loki in the tva
you think they'll do something with that
or coincidence
uh probably coincidence which i don't
like to say
very freely when it comes to marvel
actually not with marvel right
exactly uh but for that particular part
i'm gonna say coincidence but hey
who knows you might be on something
there i appreciate that super chat a lot
um
because i i because so like there's a
part in
like the black widow trailer that i
didn't see in the movie um
they in like movies like they do that
sometimes you just don't include some
saints
uh and that's the only reason why i say
i think it's a coincidence
yeah especially in trailers that happens
a lot yeah so
i mean take care galaxy spider thanks
for stopping by
this was a a a big episode
but i agree you know it was definitely
excuse me the worst of them so far yeah
definitely underwhelming because we have
such a high expectation but we got some
good intel some good information well
you have you have to
think like i mean i still really enjoyed
it i just it wasn't oh i love it yeah it
just
it wasn't the best of the three to me
but i i remember when the beginning
starts and you can go back and watch me
on this live chat
i'm like dang i love this like it's so
cool like i loved it
like seeing loki and sylvia interact
again i'm like i want y'all to get
together i know that's weird i know
you're the same person
i don't care i that i think that would
be awesome
so um i don't know there's a lot that i
really like to it and they told us a lot
of important information i just
we didn't get a big there was no climax
that's the problem there was no correct
right it literally just
cut off stopped so next week it's like
peace we're like what the hell um
bradley jones thanks for super chat if
the tva is in the quantum realm how are
they able to travel
throughout the timeline well the quantum
realm exists outside of space and time
yeah it doesn't right the quantum realm
is how you travel it's how the avengers
that's how the avengers travel through
time so ant-man spent five minutes in
five years
yeah you spent five hours in the quantum
realm and it was five years in real life
right so you know so many people oh
you know time works differently in the
quantum realm time works differently
blah blah blah blah blah you know uh
you gotta look at it as each multiverse
has its space
the quantum realm is what exists between
the multiverses where there is no space
and there is no time right and it's the
pathway
from one multiverse to the next now up
until this point kang or whoever is in
charge of the tva
has been keeping one timeline for his
own benefit
but um that's what the quantum realm is
and we're definitely going to explore
this in
the next ant-man movie oh for sure uh
haiti thank you so much for the super
chat
honestly the tva being variants makes so
much sense explains why mobius is drawn
to jet skis
90s drinks yeah hey that's a great call
right there
he's proud from the 90s and also
explains his kind of double think logic
last episode talking logie hey very
excellent point yeah i really like that
i really really like that um yeah that's
a little tick that he has yeah in his
head he's
you know he still has that little little
tick left to him
uh todd andrew thanks for super chat
directional mobius character
to go by the end i think he's gonna be
set free and if i don't get a jet ski
scene with him saying wow i'm gonna be
so pissed off
i'll add on to that question though is
this it for mobius
i really hope you show up somewhere else
i hope not as well i just don't see
but i think it is i i think i mean
unless he's about to become wolverine i
don't see how he fits into that
on wilson's wolverine that was a
curveball y'all didn't see
um we get a little carried away but it's
a lot of fun
so oh yeah you know what
automotive wasn't in this episode nope
that sucks because i love him was
he wasn't he was in like the the reason
the apocalypse place yeah he was at
roxcart
and then you gotta wonder what's
actually going on with all those
timeline things
i mean there's still a lot to get
answers about so i wouldn't worry too
much guys for those of you saying it
wasn't a great episode
but um i mean it wasn't the best episode
i still thoroughly enjoyed it
oh it was a fantastic the storyline
i do hate the ending that sucked
can we talk about his force abilities
dude okay the whole entire time
i'm like oh well he's clear he clearly
knows telekinesis
right right he's clearly very star wars
oh yeah for sure which i
i really like i mean in the last episode
he like grabbed a roomba like with his
hand he's like ah
so he knows television i like the blast
of magic
yeah that he shoots right you're like
kamehameha is it like ah
like i i like it um
so but uh going back to mobius um yeah
i don't think he's gonna turn into
anybody else i think you know it ends
with a happy ending for mobius
he gets he gets to go into a timeline
where he can continue to live his life
right or maybe gets put
back in place where he was taken from
right and then he just lives yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah the life that he is
technically like supposed to be
faded for right destined for right maybe
that's
it and yeah we'll see him on a jet ski
popping so
no way we don't see him i'm gonna be so
pissed
i mean now that we realized he had a
life outside of this
i don't i mean he can't die he can't get
destroyed i think he's gonna die
i definitely don't think he's gonna die
that'd be such a waste
yeah it was cool and i definitely think
you know talk about loki and his force
and and the close-up magic we're getting
a seed yeah that's all super fun
there's no way that by the end of the
series loki doesn't learn
the enchanting ability oh he's trying to
learn it already
that's how he wins the whole thing right
he's gonna yeah he's gonna
i think we might see some feeble
attempts
as as he fights with sylvie and he's
like almost had it or something like
that and then at the end it's gonna be
like
surprised i did it right but the thing
is and it is interesting sylvie tried to
do it to him
with zero ability well she explained
that
strong minds yeah so it shows the
strength of his mind against her because
originally it's like oh she's so much
better than him
but the reality of it is she really just
isn't he's still pretty
well pretty powerful that that's
actually what
they kind of did even out on this one um
right
loki definitely caught up to her a lot
in this one because in the first two
episodes it did seem like
oh she's way way more intense than him
yeah uh avery davis yes loki is bisexual
they confirmed that in this episode
comfor mottoed that was confirmed he had
princes and princesses
um
marvel thinks they're off the hook i
don't know for what
uh yeah so like it was a good episode
it was the least good of them all
because it had no climax
telekinesis he used his ability sorry
yeah telekinesis
um i want like a spreadsheet of all
these
i mean their powers are literally
and and loki explained it you know my
mom told me i could do anything
you know and you could see with this
with with uh sylvie that she's capable
of learning these powers she taught
herself
and i guess we learned in one division
that magic really is fluid you can
learn to do anything if you possess the
ability yeah
so you know loki and and sylvia and any
of these variants that we may come
across
of can have taught themselves or been
taught anything really
well i mean yeah that's how it was and
it's clear that all their lives were
very very different
which is interesting because like
does something happen does something
have to happen differently in time
and if so what causes that thing to
happen and why is it so i mean i guess
every tiny little rift of thing that
could possibly change creating the
multiverse i guess it's crazy how how
much things cost
waters what is up my dude wow i haven't
talked to you in a long time man
i'm living out here in utah man i don't
know if you still are
what's up man it's good to hear from you
that's crazy you know i'm back from
college parkway
um did loki falcon
a woman i don't i don't know madison his
official
i mean marvel gave him an official title
and it was gender fluid
i'm not gonna lie and pretend like i
know all the details behind all of those
things
um i don't think it comes as a surprise
loki does have the ability to change his
character right
so yeah that that did that actually kind
of confused me
too because like when that came out i
didn't say anything about it because i
had already seen episode two and i know
there's a version of loki
so i i'm like i'm like
are they talking about that like because
there's all there is a version of him
that's a girl so like yeah he is
gender fluid because there's variance
here so i don't really know but he yeah
he's definitely confirmed
our loki male loki is i would
i would call it bisexual yes a lot of
people are asking so
uh ross that's the best i can inform you
rosman lehigh
uh so hit me up on facebook dude
we'll talk um
yeah um
and i know that i know that matters to a
lot of people it matters a lot yeah i'm
not sure if
that's an important thing yeah and i'm
not sure it matters to the story that
much but you know a lot of people are
pretty happy right now and
yeah it's definitely some cool
representation oh for sure and disney's
done a good job at that
um i think the tba falls
i definitely think that it crumbles i
think it crumbles and i think it's
revealed some people
some people go home like mobius goes
home i i agree i think
you know some people are going to die
and but i think some people go home to
like
where they were supposed to be you know
like where they're supposed to be in the
main timeline
yeah or whatever timeline because if
they're all variants
is what they were called right she said
they were all various right
so there are people who somehow escaped
the normal timeline
or are they variants because they were
literally abducted from the main
timeline
by kang or by the by the time watchers
maybe i would think
because leaving the timeline makes you a
variant whether you meant to do it or
not
right exactly um i don't know i i think
from a perspective of whoever is in
charge of tva and i'm going to say
kang obviously variants happen left and
right you just keep a variant
right right right maybe maybe they're
the first variants
you know who knows i wonder what the
process of
mind control is though yeah i wonder
what that's about uh young boy tops do
you think
the timeline will break and set up
multiverse and madness i absolutely do
100 i think that's uh
exactly where we're going um they
already said
you know how many times have they said
multiverse and then like in episode one
they literally put
madness while showing the multiple
things they showed the multiverse like
they put madness on it so uh
yeah hold on diego sananez
someone was asking this could janet van
dyne have escaped the tva then
when she healed ghost it was similar to
how silvia enchants people
uh thanks for super chat um well for
starters i think
how civilian chance people is that's
that's a loki thing that's like she
she learned that she taught that herself
that's just like magic
um whereas janet van dyne didn't really
have magic she like
like harnessed energy that she absorbed
in the quantum realm
right uh i don't know if she was in the
city they flew past it remember
and um she might have just wandered
around when she
found hank she was just kind of walking
around
right uh so maybe um
but i think that's going to be a big
part i think that's going to i think
she's going to bring that
up you know post in game
she's going to bring that up because
they're going to talk about the quantum
realm some more
and then there's going to be all this
stuff like the aftermath of avengers in
game
and she's going to be like oh well
there's there was a city there that i
had to escape
or something like that so yeah i think
she could have escaped it um
but her powers are like separate from
any quantum
realm powers that may have been she's
been living in like actual timelines
and it sounds like most of them are all
self-taught because she wasn't as close
to her mom as
loki was yeah so i it's cut
it it kind of has but kind of hasn't
been established that you have to
inherit magic
abilities right like normal humans just
can't perform magic if they like read a
book
right so you know that that is that is
coming from like
her mother actually is the witch
right right it is partly right freak is
a witch
yeah so it's you know it's inherited um
but then from there you can teach
yourself so much
you can teach yourself because you have
this ability right it's you know
learning anything like you can teach
yourself how to play guitar in real life
if you
you know you don't need somebody to
teach you you can figure it out by
yourself
um trevor hadley first off utah 801 gang
second is lucky in the end
with loki or sylvia dead hey another
utahn um yeah up here in uh
lehigh uh first off
sure somebody looked i don't i don't
think so i would man i would
i'll be so bummed i would be so bummed
if they killed either one of them i
actually
really really like sylvie and i love tom
hiddleston but if they killed tom and we
ended up with sylvia i'm not mad i mean
i am mad but
better than killing both of them i
really like silva i really like the
different but i like them together
so i really want them to become like an
actual team
right well they said you could trust me
and i could trust you
and we should because we're going to
need it right at the end there before
they left yeah
yeah go ahead
hey froman the sausage king of chicago
thanks for the super chat
do you think they will introduce new
characters to the mcu
she-hulk or fantastic four since mobius
had a part and their time travels
[Music]
maybe there's a lot of potential here um
a lot a lot of potential here
them specifically i i don't know i don't
know about them specifically i think
that if anything the quantum realm
is uh probably connected to the
fantastic four
so yeah we're gonna say chris
i was gonna say my big question that i
still haven't seen any clarity for
of an answer from the episode is where
loki fits in the future of the mcu
and it's possible you know the tva
crumbles he disappears for a little bit
and shows back up in battle world
because we're talking about whether or
not he lives or dies they already said
he's not thor love and thunder which of
course
but um i just wonder where he fits in i
wonder if he'll be in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness if he'll bring
doctor strange a time stone and say here
fix this you know who knows
yeah that's that part's a little up in
the air right now i uh
like yeah uh
i hope he has a future and i hope he
comes back before secret wars because
that's a long way away from now
um yeah
i think he might opt
to this could be like a huge character
development moment
one option is he could opt to just
simply go back in his timeline
and fulfill his destiny and eventually
die
or oh man it would be really funny if he
goes back to the sacred timeline knowing
everything and doesn't get killed by
thanos
right like it's actually it actually is
like an illusion that gets killed by
thanos right
and then the ending is like him hiding
in the background like hahaha
like i out did fate right like i cheated
my destiny
right and then he lives right and then
maybe then he can become whatever he
wants right and maybe
and maybe that's what it is right maybe
maybe it really didn't die you know like
who knows um right hold on real fast
super chat eduardo warren hey hello
jordan let's talk about the fact that
agents the minutemen are all variants
from other timelines including c20
they must be held hostage uh yeah like
in a mental prison right because it's
clear
i'm just gonna say kang no i won't say
that i won't i won't act like it's
confirmed
i won't act like it's confirmed but i i
definitely need more than he already has
well i think king is behind it i mean my
personal opinion yeah i think king is
behind it it's not confirmed by any
means
so i think whoever is behind this
clearly knows something
has for all we know it's another loki
variant behind this right i mean who
who knows it would be like loki to try
to control everything i mean
wasn't that his goal anyways and the
first avengers film
so um but whoever it has
so-called taking these people's minds
hostages and taking these variants and
essentially erased their memories and
made them
just their own soldiers and workers um
that's a pretty big agenda
excuse me um i don't know i think more
and more he's got
he's got some type of infinity stone on
him who
loki he's got one on him doesn't matter
they don't work
i mean yeah work he's in the land right
so he doesn't work in the tva
it works back in the night i feel like
he would have used it in this episode
well maybe he did maybe he set back the
thing and that's how he fixes the the
time pad and he has the time it did seem
like he rewound
it was so different from his normal
magic yeah it wasn't like he was like i
got this and it wasn't like oh
telekinesis i'm just it like literally
looked like it
reversed back in place uh and actually
thanks for the super chat and that's
what he's saying wait did he reverse
time on that collapsed building with his
mind
what in the time stone magic what the
time stone magic what's that that's
great
yeah that's a good point you know maybe
he's not good maybe he did stink one
yeah
maybe he's not going out he broke the
time pad on purpose so that he didn't
get murdered by sylvia
or sylvie that's true showed her it was
because how did it break he fell on it
it wasn't even there it was magic right
so that's that doesn't make sense
he broke it knowing he can bring it back
because he's obviously handled and used
uh infinity stones before he knows how
they work he's capable of doing it
yeah so maybe he does have a time stone
and he's going to fix it and they're
going to get out of there okay
may i i i believe it and then somehow
that same time stone ends up back with
doctor strange because he's going to
need one
right well contre here thanks for the
super chat he says or she says
you think loki projects the time device
to be broken so that way you can see if
you can trust sylvia into trying to
escape and pull the real one out
yeah totally i mean you know they're
about to die
and he just maybe so okay maybe that's
this plan like
in that final moment where
she thinks they're gonna die he could
get stuff out of her right what does it
matter we're gonna die tell me
tell me everything and then after he
tells everything it's like gotcha
boom time door opens jumps through they
live
right boom it's something like that
because they got to get off the moon
or the planet or whatever it was right
and
i mean there's really no other way
unless he also has a tesseract space
stone with him and he's stolen all sorts
of things you know i don't
it's loki you never really can tell with
this guy well here's a good
point z omg it's john thanks for super
chat
don't think you use the time zone
because they did mention they only work
in their own timelines
and what are the odds he has one from
lament who mentioned that though
when did that happen though i didn't
hear that could have been in the first
it only works in their own timelines
because they went and took infinity
stones from different timelines
well the timelines create the reality of
whatever the
stones create the reality of whatever
timeline they belong to
but iron man's stones weren't from his
reality the ones from his reality were
destroyed
but according to the tba that was
supposed to happen like that so it was
part of yeah but
the time stones are still out well it
was all
part it's confusing when you get in the
freaking time drama like that no i get
it
i mean those are definitely stones from
a different timeline and they worked i
think if you bring a stone somewhere
they'll still work personally i just i
do we'll have to see i
i'm leaning more towards the fact that
he faked the thing being broken
well potentially yeah i i that seems
like a very long
i think the inclusion of the pillar and
the fact that a lot of people are asking
questions about it it's very specific
that it was added we're gonna have to go
back and like really like frame by frame
it
in slow-mo i'm gonna canadian ladder and
.25 speed it
right there you go and uh yeah because
it definitely looks like it's
definitely it was reversed like for sure
there's something
it was something weird something
something definitely was uh
and jesse's going yeah i i'm not sure if
they did actually mention that they only
worked in the timelines i'd love to go
back and rewatch what the ancient one
said
and see if they said anything in the
first episode but good point
uh i think in the comics it's that way
it could be wrong though
so well
um kmk if stones didn't work from other
timelines iron man would still be live
yeah this is what chris was kind of
saying
um but i mean he'd probably be dead
thanos would have killed him but
that's beside right yeah my argument is
the tva
said it was supposed to happen which
would mean it actually
still took place in the sacred timeline
because i
to the to the tva and the time creepers
the sacred timeline
is whatever they have chosen is supposed
to happen
so time travel's supposed to happen that
doesn't matter it's still in the
timeline
right they're supposed to time travel
inside of the sacred timeline
and it all happens that way right
captain america was supposed to do that
the avengers were supposed to do that
so technically it would still exist in
the timeline so
but what if the tva didn't exist and i
took a time stone from one multiverse
into the next one for my big huge secret
wars fight
because we've learned that the tva is
completely arbitrary then there's
it's all madness that's cool right so
we're in the multiverse of madness and
loki has this drawer of infinity stones
and takes all of them in for this
freaking
battle they'll work i would imagine
so unless they do establish some rule
that
they only only specific ones work and
which
actually that that would make things
more interesting if they didn't work
because i feel like it would be too easy
if they worked
you know i mean it would be it would be
a problem
it would be easy yeah um
the crazy thing about this and i'm sure
a lot of people have touched on it
you've probably touched on it
multiverse open stays open i mean we
could get another thanos we could see a
different iron man we could see
a never ending possibility of you know
we could see a multiverse worth thanos
i want to see that actually i would love
to see that
because i don't necessarily disagree
with his logic you know
[Laughter]
quote quote it here first you heard it
first
chris chris would have eliminated half
of the universe
i'm team thanos guys sorry oh
let's we gotta go let's go we're gonna
cancel him
but i think it would be interesting to
see it really would be exactly right
it's almost like a live-action what-if
where it all happened
and that's where we're headed with this
loki series and it's it's incredible
yeah i see a lot of people saying that
the episode was slow boring and it had a
cliffhanger but a lot of plot
development here and i'm super excited
to see where it goes i'm
i'm pumped me too before we log off here
jonathan
grenandos made another good point going
back to the
the stones theories what do you think
about him having a stone
and then using that to power the device
she said they needed a huge power source
yeah maybe it has a pocket full of
stones one of them is the power stone
and one of those time stone which is how
i reverse that pillar and the power
stone is how they
you know how they do it um
kmk the sacred timeline consists of
multiple timelines though also
by now we should know the tv is full of
crap that's also true too
we uh we can't necessarily buy into what
the tva said now can we because
it's crap so thank you cam k and thank
you jonathan
ran out of this for the super chat oh i
just wait what happened
ah thank you gaming god it says message
retracted um so i don't see it
apologize that but well it looks like
it's time for us to get to work and do a
breakdown
of episode three um there was a lot of
important details and episodes a little
little fine comb detail yeah yes it
didn't have
um a big climax there was
there wasn't like huge huge huge things
that happened but i mean there really
were if you think about the tva
essentially being exposed uh that was
crazy it's
crazy that's big it's a big detail and i
again i i
i thought that because i'm like why are
the timekeepers creating all these
different peoples with different
freaking personalities like if it's me
i am just freaking out that's how you
get owen wilson yeah
i i mean like i'm if it's me i'm a
timekeeper i'm just making everybody
the same right like mindless people you
can do whatever all these people have
different personalities stuff like that
uh hey alexa thanks again every every
week coming through with the super chats
super appreciate it one can't tell you
how much i'm enjoying these discussions
i am glad we really enjoyed them too
uh according to tva sylvie is the bad
one it must be stopped
if this is king behind it why do you
think he wants to stop her because i
because he he it sounds like he controls
everything right he
he's the master of time travel we can go
forward he could go backwards
he could go outside of time and based
off of what rensselaer was saying he is
actually like
forging what happens to his destiny
so she wants to kill that right she
wants to essentially get to him so
i mean she essentially wants to kill him
right if he is the
you know the person in charge she wants
to kill him so of course he wants to
stop her
um and he wants it all just to be
one timeline and she wants to chaos
or whatever her backstory is that we
still don't have yet
uh luff
loft i'm so sorry if i you know i know
how to pronounce that
uh thank you for the super chat sylvie
equals sylvia lush and enchantress
if so loki gave her powers and that
would explain why she doesn't have her
own mom and that's why she's a variant
um i personally think
it's loki and
they just threw made her name sylvia as
a little
uh easter egg to enchantress i don't
think it's enchantress i think they
might give her some powers just like
hella was actually really enchantress as
well and they gave
her a lot of enchantress powers from
ragnarok hello from ragnarok
but i'm i'm pretty sure you know she she
said she was loki
she just doesn't go by that name anymore
so i don't think
i i don't maybe she was a twin she had a
brother maybe hey there you go
oh that's true yeah she's gonna know
maybe that's gonna
come up but uh who knows there are so
many theories we could be here all night
let's let's stop the super chats guys i
super appreciate them obviously yeah
guys
guys slow down with those chris is
getting too many
guys i need you to stop thank you for
the super chat
but we're about to log off and i don't
want to miss any which is why i'm asking
to stop
uh sylvia's lucky's mom no i don't think
so i i really do think
i do i really really do think she's loki
i think she's a loki too i agree with
that i chose to get make her name
sylvie she might be a reincarnated loki
right there'll be a story and we'll get
it there's going to be a story we're
going to find out a little bit more
about her life
and i liked her a lot i liked her
so we'll see we'll see but hey everybody
thanks for
for joining we love these discussions
afterwards we love to watch parties uh
during a big shout out to mr anderson
for being an awesome mod
uh shout out to everybody who just came
tonight whether you were talking
super chatting or just chilling and
watching we love you all
um we got lots of work to do so we're
gonna go ahead and get started
um and even though it wasn't the best
episode of look yet it was really good
uh which had a climax part to it but
maybe it's all about to go down in the
next episode
so uh maybe i could come up with some
good theories in the meantime
to keep you all occupied during the week
also don't forget to go to no this way
good night madison cosmic culture
subscribe to go go go right now go go go
it's our other channel cosmic culture uh
you'll find chris on there every day and
me on there sometimes
uh put in the chat chris put in the chat
what are you doing put your link to
everybody
there hurry up everybody subscribe to
cosmic culture happy
if we how about this 50 000 subscribers
chris cuts his hair uh
a hundred thousand no fifty thousand
subscribers and chris cuts his hair
yo everybody do warren a favor and click
that link and subscribe
yeah do me a favor
i posted it did my my chat completely
stopped actually
oh there we go oh oh yeah i just sped up
like a lot so
but anyways thanks spike love you all
bye everybody thank you so much for
joining us woof